[Music]
have you ever eaten this
all those have you drunk that
you have good well these creations are
all from one man
william a mitchell an all-american food
chemist
a junk food wizard as such and his road
to sugar glory would change the world's
sweet tooth
forever
[Music]
bill mitchell started working at general
foods in 1939.
his job was to create new foods for the
world to sink their teeth into
and who would be best to talk about such
an inventor than an old colleague
marv rudolph they worked together for
six years in the same lab
bill was the inventor at general foods
if you looked up inventor in the
dictionary there was probably a picture
of bill mitchell next to the word
he knew what amplified flavors he knew
what
colors to use to make something more
attractive
if you had a problem he was the guy to
go to
management tried to promote bill many
times and he said no just keep me in my
lab that's all i want to do
bill had a superhero beginning just like
the hulk or dr manhattan
after his lab exploded and he survived
he was eating a beaker of alcohol and
the beaker had a crack
it just exploded they said he had burns
over 80 percent of his body and he was
in terrible pain
he managed to come back from that
explosion that accident
and start a career that was exemplary
the time is 1956 mitchell was hard at
work trying to carbonate kool-aid a
popular powdered soft drink
so he said why can't i add carbon
dioxide molecules to sugar
that was a great leap forward and thus
pop rocks were born
the infamous popping candy you might
have heard the few urban legends
pop rocks and cola together will make
your stomach explode
no way it wasn't true absolutely not
but the rumor would never die and people
would call up to general foods
and they'd say are you the company that
killed that dear little boy
soon after mitchell was on a roll he
created a powder when mixed together
with water would create a bright orange
liquid
and it was 94 sugar but it had vitamin c
he invented tang he invented the orange
flavoring system
which was much more intense than just a
typical orange flavor
and fun fact tang even made its way to
space
first of all john glenn's mercury flight
in 1962
it was used to make the spacecraft's
water supply stop tasting so much like
metal
[Music]
now it's 1967. earlier in the year
mitchell had patented a faster setting
jello
quick set jello was a very useful
invention because you didn't have to
wait for the jello to set which took
hours and you cut the time in half but
why stop there
only a few months later he was hard at
work ladies and gentlemen
i think this is mitchell's finest
invention
cool whip oh yeah cool whip was the
first
freeze thought stable non-dairy whipped
cream
you can whip cream but you freeze it and
it's going to separate
that was a huge product a huge success
for general foods
[Music]
william a mitchell was granted 44
patents in 35 years
an incredible feat but like any inventor
some did work and some didn't
one of them that didn't make it was dry
alcohol
he would take wet alcohol and mix it
with this fluffy maltodextrin
and it would stay dry there are problems
with that
but it does work the funny thing about
that was
general foods was a completely
non-alcoholic
company you couldn't even bring a bottle
of beer into general foods it was
forbidden management said what the heck
bill what are you doing
it's a shame i kind of like the sound of
that one so
a toast of tang and pop rocks on the
side to william
a mitchell the greatest junk food
chemist
that ever lived
you